He said,
the streets are ready to cease fire,
and I say yes,
but it's for
reconstitute their potential.
You're fine,
but that's crazy,
please.
And when we start it's fire?
And so we don't have to
think about resuming the fight.
However,
he told Manuel bomba that the
president zelenski was ready and knew
that in the end he would have to accept 1
consultation of the populations concerned
by the borders.
And everyone understands.
Simply meaning
that what was true before the war
may no longer be true
while the war took place
and that some who eventually
felt more on one side,
may feel more about the other,
when we agree to set it on fire,
when we agree to the development of
populations concerned,
when we agree to demilitarize
everything surrounding nuclear reactors,
so what obstacle to punishment?
France,
of course,
we say,
ruble,
putin is not a reliable interlocutor,
why not?
But then the fight must still be waged,
it must be brought before the public,
threaten to send troops,
say that there is no limit,
discuss France's nuclear capacity
and claim to extend it to all the nations of Europe.
This absurdity.
You imagine 1 button
which gives access
to the use of the nuclear bomb with 28 fingers on it.
What is the meaning of such an idea?
None,
if not to scare whom
to the supposed opponent therefore,
if he is afraid
to force him to put himself in a situation of retaliation.
This is how this president,
believer inked I know only to the strategic ambiguity,
managed to touch 1 straw in the indescribable,
already with its own allies,
but also with the opponents.
Because we got the fucking answer.
And of course
is a dangerous head of state.